[APPLAUSE]
[CLASSICAL MUSIC - BEETHOVEN]
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
LUCIA NOWIK: Well,
we're going to introduce
ourselves real quick.
So we all are from Juilliard.
And my name's Lucia.
STRAUSS SHI: I'm Strauss.
KEITH WILLIAMS: I'm Keith.
SOPHIA SUN: I'm Sophia.
LUCIA NOWIK: And we are all
in our undergraduate there.
And now we're going to
play some Haydn, yes?
[CLASSICAL MUSIC - HAYDN]
[APPLAUSE]
KEITH WILLIAMS: So we're going
to play the last movement
of a Finnish composer's
string quartet Edvard Grieg.
AUDIENCE: Norwegian, Norwegian.
KEITH WILLIAMS: No-- oh wow.
Oh, man.
[LAUGHTER]
Thank you.
No, you're just keeping
me on task here.
And wow, that was really wrong.
And he wrote this towards
the end of his life.
And it's just a
really dramatic piece
with lots of emotion and
also really kind of fun.
But I don't know
if anybody knows
what a tarantella dance is.
It's a dance that's
kind of fast and crazy.
And this is basically
one of those.
And it's a dance
that-- when you get bit
by a really poisonous
spider, you dance yourself
to death in kind of a
joyous rapture a little bit
in this particular case.
So you'll hear a
lot of happiness
with this kind of
crazy twist behind it.
And that's on purpose.
So let's hit it.
[LAUGHTER]
[CLASSICAL MUSIC - GREIG]
[APPLAUSE]